So we expected it to happen, and it finally is
my pillow CEO, Michael Andell, who I refer to as
Mike Pillow, has been sued by Dominion voting
systems because of his continued and persistent
bogus weaponized election fraud claims.
Mike Lyndell is a right wing pillow manufacturer
based in Minnesota. He mostly advertises on
right wing media like Fox News and Newsmax and on
or some combination of those. He became close to
the president when he showed up at the White House
relatively early in the coronavirus pandemic and
was part of a sort of promotional tour in which
Donald Trump announced that these various
companies that love Trump will be retooling
their factories to make and 95 masks. We
don't really know if or when that actually
happened. But in any case, at his speech thanking
Donald Trump for his involvement in making PPE,
Mike Lyndell said that he believes Donald Trump
is a gift from God and it only went downhill from
there. In the post-election period. Mike Lendell
became sort of a fixture on right wing media and
various wacky, kooky podcasts, saying he has all
the proof it was stolen by Joe Biden and Dominion
Voting Systems was a big part of it. He will now
have to mount a legal defense. And if he really
does have the proof that Dominion did whatever
it is he thinks they did in the 2012 election,
he's going to get the chance to prove it because
that's what you get to do. In defamation cases,
Dominion is seeking more than one point three
billion dollars in damages. The lawsuit says that
Mike Lyndell, quote, exploited false claims about
election fraud to support his company's sales. And
Mike Lyndell has responded by saying, quote, I'm
very happy that they've done this. I'm ready to go
to court. I have all the evidence that anyone
would ever want to see. Now, you might remember
that in an interview with The New York Times
last month, early February, I believe it was in
January, Lyndell said he welcomes a lawsuit from
Dominion. They had sent him a sort of legal letter
warning him, if you don't stop, we will sue and we
might sue anyway. And they have sued. And I guess
we'll see how it all works out for Mike Pelo. Now,
this is going to be Mike Pillow. This is going to
be fascinating because as has been the issue with
defamation lawsuits for a long time, defamation
statutes have been a thing for a while proving
that what you said is true is a valid defense
to defamation. If Mike Pillow's allegations
are true, it is by definition not defamation.
Defamation can take two forms, slander or libel.
Slander is spoken. Defamation, libel is written,
defamation. If Mike Pelo can prove that Dominion
voting systems and again, it's hard to understand
what he even claims. But if Mike Pelo can prove
that they did whatever he claims that they did,
he would be off scot free and wouldn't be
liable for anything now. I love the idea of
Mike having to go to court with his so-called
evidence, but my guess is if I had to bet on it,
that whatever lawyers Mike Lyndell actually hires
are going to tell him, Mike, the way to fight this
is not to go to court and try to prove voter
fraud. I can't imagine any serious lawyer would
even take this case if the strategy is going to be
we're going to go in there and prove that Dominion
did whatever it is Mike Lyndell claims that
they did, it will either be pled out or settled.
Mike Lyndell might end up apologizing, like Alex
Jones has about I think it was Chobani yogurt or
something like that. And it actually reminds
me of if you think back to not that long ago,
Trump second impeachment, his first cadre of
lawyers quit. And one of the bits of news that we
got around that was that Trump wanted that first
slate of attorneys to defend Trump by proving the
election was stolen, therefore legitimizing or
legitimating. Yes, that's a word legitimizing the
inciting of the riot. And reportedly Trump's
first slate of lawyers said that's a crazy idea,
that that doesn't make sense. They ended up
parting ways. But ultimately, Trump's legal
team did not defend him by saying the election
was stolen. They defended him by saying he didn't
actually incite the riot. So we will follow this.
Remember that Rudy Giuliani has also been sued by
Dominion voting systems. And we're going to follow
it and see. Where this ultimately ends up at